we are going to look at the difference
between an idea and a true business
opportunity we're going to look at how
the best entrepreneurs recognize and
evaluate opportunities then we're going
to look at how they pursue them the way
they gather resources with the financial
resources or human resources that help
them go realize their dream
so the way we're going to do this and
learn about entrepreneurship is through
a variety of teaching methods we're
going to have a team of teachers I'm
going to be joined by some wonderful Lex
students who are now professionals one
is in a start-up and it's going to bring
that perspective the other is a venture
capitalist and he will bring that
perspective as an investor together with
me who is a professor of this topic
we're going to share a bunch of material
and content in our lectures we're also
though going to lead you through
exercises that could be case studies but
it also could be your own development of
an idea to see whether it's an
opportunity or not along with readings
and videos it should be an exciting time